hey let me help you with something
because I think we've gotten a lot of
things confused out here if you want to
correct someone whoever heeds correction
gains understanding if you want to hold
someone accountable to better behavior
there is only one way you can do that
well there's only one effective way you
can do that you have to have a
relationship with them if you don't have
a relationship with someone you are not
in a position to hold them accountable
or to correct them rebuke them if you
want to use an old Bible word you're not
you're not going to change someone's
behavior now that the exception I said
effectively the exception is you can
actually get people to change their
behavior by threatening them with some
sort of power you have over them but
it's not effective because it doesn't
create long-term change because there's
no understanding it's merely compliance
and so if enough people threaten the
politician and the politician changes
their vote that they were not corrected
they were not held accountable they
merely were threatened into that
position and then the next time that
vote comes up they'll vote the wrong way
because they haven't changed their mind
their mind and their heart weren't
changed and we add but we have a whole
culture that feels like they have the
right to now hold people accountable or
rebuke people or correct people with
whom they don't have a relationship an
example would be when someone's angry
and they tweet or they go on Facebook
and they say you should you should never
do that and they they say I you know I'm
with you know this generation has these
wonderful just saying and I'm
disappointed and and they insult someone
and say because I'm out here in the
Twitter universe somewhere and I don't
like you you should change and you
should be willing to accept my input
well the answer is is that no one's
going to accept your input unless they
have a relationship with you and so when
I you know some little 26 year old or 24
year old or 38 year old or 58 year old
gets mad at me on Twitter
it doesn't correct me I don't change
because it on a relationship with that
person and the only relationship I have
with them is when they came when they
drove by on their Twitter account and
insulted me and that's supposed to make
me want to change it's not how it works
folks it's a relationship to correct
someone otherwise you're just barking at
the wind your dog chasing a car you're
kind of pitiful wouldn't know what to do
if you caught it and but this idea that
somehow you have the obligation to trash
so-and-so on the Internet
and I see you people do it with these
portal college football players these
are 18 year old kids and some of you
people they're supposed grown-ups rip
them to shreds because they didn't catch
a football in a game you're pitiful
human beings you're pitiful human beings
you have no relationship with that kid
you're not in a position to coach them
to play football and you somehow feel
the right to go on and rip someone to
shreds you see it in the comments after
articles all the time that are written
about situations and you feel some of
you feel the right your righteous
indignation like somebody cares what you
think so you can't correct people you
can't hold people accountable that you
don't have a relationship with doesn't
work so if you want to guide someone you
have to build a relationship with them
I've have the privilege of having a
relationship over the radio with
millions of you
and it is a privilege and it's an honor
and you trust what I've said about
things and so when I say something that
makes you feel uncomfortable it causes
you to stop and think because of our
relationship no it's not a personal
relationship but we do have that
relationship it is a bit one-way I
understand that because you haven't
listened to you so I don't have as much
relationship with you other than I'm
glad you're there and we appreciate you
but you're not in the position to really
threaten me
just because you listen and that
interesting it's an interesting dynamic
and it's something to kind of think
about because the anger and the angst
that is out there in our culture right
now is and the polarization of political
parties and liberal ideology and
conservative ideology and you know CNN
and Fox and you know Rush and Sean and
whoever ad and you know the polarization
the loud voices but very few people are
stopping to actually interact anymore
and so nothing gets accomplished except
just barking at the wind and chasing a
car I and and some of people think they
can enter into the you know blogosphere
or the Twitter sphere or the Facebook
world and have that same kind of a voice
in it it's not working all it's doing is
embarrassing you and it's amazing to me
that people think they can say things
caustic and then when someone responds
they say oh he's thin-skinned one guy
said Ramsey's prickly quickly I like
that word I'm prickly kind of am like a
little stickers on there yeah like touch
a thornbush it's you know that kind of
thing that's things time to think about
and all it was was I you know you
insulted me on Twitter and I actually
responded I said you're outta line well
you're thin-skinned no your honor you
know you call me condescending and I say
you're out of line but I'm the one
that's insulting isn't that interesting
so I have enjoyed the whole Twitter
experience it's an interesting study in
human nature and an interesting study
and digital courage
people will say crap they would never
have the courage to say in your face to
walk into our building and stand here
and talk to me and say the exact same
thing 0% 0% of them have that much
courage and very interesting it's very
interesting and so you know that's a
thing for you young people to think
about don't put a picture and these kids
man these teenagers on Twitter Wow with
the language
don't type something into the digital
world words of yours associated with
your name don't post a picture of
yourself that you wouldn't put on a
billboard on the side of the highway if
you wouldn't say it on a billboard on
the side of the highway where your
grandmother sees it your mother sees it
your school principal sees it your
future employers see it your past
employers see it your friends see it
your pastor sees it if you wouldn't put
it on a billboard where all of those
people see it with those words beside
your name in your face and you wouldn't
put your picture that you're posting
that's really embarrassing for you then
don't post it on anywhere on the
internet on Facebook on Twitter anything
else because that's your personal brand
and you're destroying the brand that is
you in other words you're destroying the
credibility that you have because you're
showing yourself to have no character
you're showing yourself to be out of
control and basically a coward throwing
a grenade in the digital space because
you don't have the courage to do
something like that in person you got to
be really careful with this folks
because stuff that has been said about
friends of mine that are in the media in
the digital world would never be said to
their face emperor
because they're people that are saying I
have no courage have no backbone so if
you wouldn't say it to their face and
you wouldn't put it on a billboard don't
put it on the Internet
you